a woman who divorced her husband while
he was suffering from testicular cancer
has revealed why she has no regrets
janafry a life coach from Saint
Petersburg Russia who now lives in
Singapore got married when she was just
22 years old and looking back she wishes
she hadn't tied the knot before she was
30. her ex-husband who was 15 years her
senior was diagnosed with testicular
cancer three months into her marriage
and she stayed with him for another five
years now from here we're told all about
Jana's husband's cancer diagnosis which
obviously affected Yana herself most of
all she is the main character she is the
one with the power to create and destroy
the whole universe revolves around her
and now her husband's terminal illness
revolves around her too her his terminal
illness was cramping her style ruining
her vibe